All right, everybody!
Welcome to my talk.
ES2016, the evolution of
JavaScript.
First a little bit about me.
My name is Jafar Husain.
I'm a tech
lead at Netflix, I work for Falcor, an upcoming
open data platform, which
we intend to release pretty soon, and I'm
also one of Netflix's
representatives on TC-39, which is JavaScript's
standard's committee.
This
talk used to be called ES7, the evolution
of JavaScript, but something
happened a couple of committee meetings ago.
We decided to change ES6 to
ES2015 and ES7 to ES2016.
I want to explain this name change.
We as a
committee want to start shipping JavaScript
every year.
Just the way you
would ship software in an agile way, we want
to add features and ship them
quickly.
That's why we have this new name.
The language formerly known as
ES6 is ES2015 and the upcoming language version
is ES2016.
ES2016 features are
already starting to roll on the browsers.
For example, there's
object.observe in Chrome right now.
And it's important to know that
ES2015 and ES2016 were developed concurrently.
So although there was this big
-- many, many years between ES5 and ES2015,
what the committee is doing is
they're developing new features.
In the latest version of the language, at
the same time that they're developing features
in the next version of the
language.
And that's exciting, because it actually helps
us plan the future of
JavaScript.
We don't have to do everything in one release.
We can add
features today to ES2015 and we can build
on them, with the hopes of building
on them later in ES2016.
So the big story about ES2016 is: how do we
make
async programming easier?
I think there's probably some folks out there
who
think this is kind of a hard problem.
Right?
Any pain out there, about async
programming?
Quite a few people, I'm guessing.
So starting with ES5, we
introduced something to make your life a little
bit easier, which is arrow
functions.
I'm not going to dwell on this too long, but
as of ES2015,
you're now able to write this way.
A lot of people are familiar with arrow
functions.
I'm not going to spend too long on this.
This definitely helps
when you have a lot of callback.
Arrow functions are an improvement, but can
we do better?
What if you can write async programs without
any callbacks at
all?
How does that sound?
Right?
Yeah?
So we all know that blocking is easy.
Right?
Blocking is no problem.
Blocking -- let's imagine for a moment this
function which gets a stock
price, calls, gets stock symbol, which makes
a blocking XHR request, one
of those things we're never supposed to do.
Never make a blocking request.
But it's easy, because we can wait for the
request to come back, block when it
does, and pass the symbol for that stock and
get the price for it.
We know
blocking is easy but it produces a terrible
User Experience.
Because user
might be sitting there and our UI is not responding
to mouse clicks
while we're making our request.
So that's something you're not
supposed to do in JavaScript.
But when I say blocking, I want you to
think pulling.
When we call a function and receive the output
in the return
position of that functioning, we're pulling
the value of that function.
To
the left hand side, pulling the value out.
So when I say blocking, I mean
pulling, and that means data is delivered
in the return position of the
function.
That's how most functions are in JavaScript.
Most functions
return their data in the return position.
But what if we decide that we want to wait
instead of block?
We don't want to
block the UI, waiting for the output and not
being able to respond to user
input.
We want to be able to just wait.
Well, in order to wait in
JavaScript, waiting means pushing.
What it means is you hand the callback to
that function and that function pushes the
value, the result of that
function, in the argument position of your
callback.
So this is a
thing you would see in node.
You hand the function to callback and it pushes
the value, the result, in the argument position.
So as soon as we try to do
that, as soon as we try to wait in JavaScript,
we very rapidly find ourselves
in the pyramid of doom.
If you've done a lot of node.js programming,
you
probably know what I mean.
Your code takes on this pyramid-like structure
that
you see there on the left hand side.
So on the left hand side here, with get stock
price, we're doing a
blocking function.
Just the same function you saw earlier.
But as soon as you
want to move to waiting on the right hand
side, take a look at how much
more complicated our function becomes.
Why is there so much more code
here?
For one thing, it's because we're doing the
job that JavaScript usually
does for us.
If an error is encountered anywhere in this
function, now as
soon as we're using callbacks to forward on
those errors, we're responsible.
For making sure that those errors get forwarded
up.
Whereas when we're
doing blocking code, we have try/catch to
rely on.
So as soon as -- the
problem really, what's going on here, is since
JavaScript doesn't expect
functions to wait, in JavaScript, they sort
of expect functions to block
-- there's no support for reporting errors
this way, and the language can't
provide you with any sort of support, whether
it's loops or try/catch, so
you're kind of on your own.
But what if waiting were just as easy as blocking?
What if JavaScript
understood this concept of functions that
waited, and it could provide you
syntactical support just like try/catch, and
you could use loops, for
example, to repeat asynchronous functions?
Well, in ES2015, we got a little
closer to this vision, with promises.
Now, the way I think most of you are
probably familiar with promises -- most of
you have been exposed to them
at this point.
But the way to think about a promise is that
it's an
object that represents the eventual value
of an asynchronous operation.
So
if you want to get the value from a promise,
you call then and pass to
callbacks.
One is for receiving data if the asynchronous
operation
succeeded.
That's on the left hand side there.
And the other callback is for
receiving the error if the asynchronous operation
failed.
So it's sort of
like a promise is like a present that you
unwrap, and great -- if everything
worked out, you get a value.
But if things go bad, you can get an error.
So
now let's take a look at that same previous
example, waiting with
callbacks, and that pyramid of doom structure
you see there, and let's see
how we can now do the same thing with promises.
So what's happened here is promises actually
take care -- they catch any
errors that occur, and forward them up until
they're actually caught,
where you pass an error handler, notice on
get stock price, we pass an
error handler.
We don't have to catch errors at every possible
step in the
function.
We just catch errors in one place and the
promise type will catch
errors and forward it up until -- there's
a function provided to handle
that error.
So what's actually happening is that type
is doing the job that
try/catch does for you in the language.
So that's how we got back down to
that nice little piece of code.
That's an improvement.
No more
pyramid of doom.
It's not bad.
But why can't we just write code that looks
pretty much the same, regardless of whether
it's waiting or blocking, right?
What if we could just write our algorithm
and make it easy to switch that
algorithm between waiting and blocking?
That promise code you saw on the
previous slide looks different from the synchronous
blocking code
you saw earlier.
As of ES2015, you will now be able to wait
like this.
So using generator functions and the yield
keyword, which is something
I'm going to tell but later, you can actually
write code that looks
pretty much exactly like the blocking code,
but instead waits.
It doesn't
block.
And so you can allow handling of user input,
but you can write
your code top to bottom.
More, you can take advantage of looping
constructs to block flow in an asynchronous
way.
So on the right hand side I
can use loops and I can even use try/catch.
How do we make this work in
JavaScript?
In order to explain that to you, I have to
explain generators.
But the metapoint I want you to understand
here is that pulling and pushing
are symmetrical.
You can do the exact same thing -- write your
code
precisely the same way, whether it's pulling
or pushing.
It's kind of a
detail.
Somehow be able to write your logic and after
the fact decide
whether you want that function to push or
you want it to be a pulling
function.
Anything that you can push, you can pull out
of a function.
I'm
going to demonstrate that in just a moment.
So in order to understand how that works,
I'm going to explain you to the
most powerful and most misunderstood feature
in ES2015, and that is
generator functions.
Hands up -- quick, how many people have heard
of
generator functions?
Great.
Quite a few people.
How many people understand
them?
Right.
Okay.
So that's -- hopefully I want to rectify that
today.
If
you get one thing out of this talk, it'll
at least be a slightly better
understanding of what generator functions
are, because as I said, they're
really powerful.
At a high level, this is how I want you to
think about
generator functions.
It's a function that can return multiple values.
Well, you can already make a function that
returns multiple values.
Throw a few values in an array.
But this allows you to do that more
efficiently.
This is what generator functions look like
in ES2015.
This yield
keyword is like an intermediary return.
It runs in the middle and you can
return more values.
So if you're consuming the data from a generator
function, this is what it looks like.
In order to get the data out, you
request an iterator.
By calling that function, what comes out is
an
iterator.
An iterator is what you can call next on,
and then what happens
is the function evaluates to the first yield,
and then stops and returns that
value.
And then it pops out of its little tuple which
contains the value
that was returned and a Boolean telling you
whether or not there are
more values.
So if done is False, we can call next again,
and execution is
going to resume and move to the next yield
and then pause and then return
you another tuple, saying that value -- we
know we have more to do, so I'm
going to keep calling next, until finally
we get return and we get our last
value, and we know we're done, because done
is True.
If I want you to
write a get numbers function today in ES2015,
you would probably roll a sync
machine.
Calls next and I get the next value.
Let's look at this
Fibonacci sequence function here.
And I'm going to show you what it desugars
to, from ES2015 to ES5.
So you can see I've got this stink variable
on the
left hand side and that's keeping track on
of where I am.
And I'm
returning the object with this method, that's
the iterator you saw earlier.
Now, what this function actually is doing
-- you can see here what generator
functions do is they figure out every possible
state that that function
can be in and they build a state machine.
So this get Fibonacci sequence can
be in three different states when you call
next.
Where it's supposed to
return zero at the beginning, where it's supposed
to return one, and finally
whatever it returned last time, whatever it
returned before that, add
them together, and return them.
In JavaScript, in ES2015, this
generator function is actually smart enough
to figure that out and build
this state machine for you.
And what it's really doing is it's turning
what
looks like a push.
Notice on the left hand side here -- yield
kind of looks
like a push.
Imagine yield was a callback.
Right?
And there was brackets
around that yield.
The code looks like we're pushing the data.
But the
compiler turns it into code that pulls by
building a state machine on the left
hand side.
So that's effectively what generator functions
do.
They let you
write code that looks like you're pushing
information when in fact it
turns it inside out and then it uses pull
for the control flow.
So for each one of these yields, we have that
return which returns the
tuple, the value, and the done, and increments
the state variables, as it goes
along, and that's how we move through the
states.
This allows us to use
iteration.
The whole process of pulling a value out of
it until you're done
is called iteration.
And it involves a consumer and a producer.
The
consumer requests an iterator from the producer,
and then it pulls the value
out by calling next.
So the producer emits a value.
Right?
And why do I
say it's pull?
Well, notice I'm getting the value out in
the return position
of next.
So I'm pulling functions out.
I'm pulling values out.
I keep pulling
values out, until finally I pull out a value
and the producer says you're
done.
So that's how iteration works.
You keep pulling values out until
the producer says I'm done.
No more data.
So if generator functions return iterators,
why are they called generator
functions?
Why don't we just call them iterator functions?
There's more
than meets the eye when it comes to generator
functions.
A generator is
actually built out of two different interfaces.
The iterator you saw
earlier, where you can call next and get out
the little tuple saying what
the value is and whether you're done -- it
also has an entirely other side,
a split personality, which is an observer
interface, which gets push
values.
So a generator is both a source of data, which
you can pull data out
of, but it's also a sync which you can push
data into.
So these two sources
combined create a generator.
A generator is an iterator.
You can pull a
value out.
If you attempt to pull a value out, you can
get an error, because
it might throw if you call next.
And finally you can pull a value out and
get that done:true in that little tuple.
So there's three types of
notifications that a producer can tell you
during iteration.
I've got some
data.
An error.
And here's your final value.
You can see all of those
notifications in reverse on the observer side.
So when you call next on a
generator, you can also push a value in by
passing a value in the argument
position of next.
You can also send an error in, by calling
throw, and finally, you can send
in a final value by calling return.
So why does an observer have this sort of
split personality of both being a source of
data and sync?
It's to solve a
little problem.
And that's that iteration only allows data
to flow in one
direction.
Whereas with generators, two functions can
effectively have a
conversation.
Have a long running conversation.
I put a value out.
I push a
value back in.
I pull a value out, I push a value back in.
Why would I want
to do that?
What does that buy me?
It allows us to use a very powerful pattern
that I think a lot of people in the room are
going to be using in the next few
years called asynchronous iteration.
So we have our generator function and
the first thing I want you to notice is that
I told you to use a mental
model for understanding yield.
The model I gave you was -- it's sort of
like an intermediary return.
But in this particular piece of code,
it's used like an expression.
We're siding to the result of a yield.
So
what's that about?
Here we have a producer function.
And what it's actually going to produce if
you notice what's on the right
hand side of those yields -- it's going to
be an iterator of promises.
So
we're going to pull promises out of this iterator,
and then what we're going
to do is we're going to resolve those promises
and then push the value back
in.
And so we need a consumer to go along with
this producer.
The
consumer's job is just going to be to pull
out, by calling next, pull out
promises, resolve those promises, and push
the value back in.
And what
you're going to see later is when you push
a value back into the generator,
the whole yield expression gets replaced with
the value that you put back in.
And this is the key.
This is the recipe to allow you guys to write
code that
looks -- that looks like it blocks, but actually
waits.
So let's take a look
at how this works.
We have this spawn function, which I'm going
to define
in just a moment.
Think about as the consumer -- it's pulling
promises out
of this iterator promise.
So if I run this, what spawn is going to do
is
it's going to produce a promise which will
be the eventual result of get
stock price, after we resolve the get stock
symbol promise and the get stock
symbol price promise.
So when I run this code eventually it's going
to
run the price of an individual stock.
In this case, Pfizer stock.
Well,
asynchronous iteration works this way.
You've got a consumer and a producer.
The consumer requests a generator from the
producer.
And then calls
next, pulls out the first value, but notice
-- execution suspends at the
first yield.
And what we're yielding back is a promise.
It's a promise
that will eventually resolve to the symbol
for Pfizer.
And so that promise
is handed to the consumer, and the consumer
and the producer have an
agreement.
The consumer says -- every promise I pull
out, I'm going to
resolve, and then I'm going to push the value
back into the producer.
So the consumer calls then on the promise,
waits until it's resolved, and
then calls next again, on the generator, from
the producer, except this time
-- notice we pass PFE in the argument position
of next.
We're effectively
pushing a value in, at the same time as we're
pulling a value out.
So we
send PFE back in, and now I want you to look
at what happens to the yield
expression.
It effectively gets replaced with a value
that we get pushed
in, and then execution resumes, and pauses
at the next yield.
So now the
consumer's pushed in a value, and at the same
time, they're pulling out
another promise.
This time for the price of that particular
stock.
So
agreement between the consumer and the producer
-- the consumer is going to
resolve that promise.
And when it gets a value, it's going to call
next
again, and this time, push 2783 back into
the producer.
That replaces
yield.
And we continue and stop at the final return
value.
So now we've
actually returned -- it's not a promise.
It's just a plain old value.
Back to
the consumer.
And we said -- hey, we're done.
We're not going to give you
any more data.
At this point, the consumer takes the promise
that it
returned, the spawn function, and it resolves
it to the final value, 2783.
So pictures are great.
But let's take a look at some code.
So here I have get stock price.
And then I have this spawn function, which
consumes it.
So notice at the bottom I'm calling spawn,
but I'm passing in
the generator that comes out of get stock
price into spawn.
And what's
going to come out of that is a promise that's
eventually going to resolve
to the final price of that stock.
So I run this.
And what happens is we
immediately create a promise inside of the
spawn function.
And execution
runs to the very bottom and hits this onresult
function.
And this function
is basically my way of asynchronously looping
and continuing to resolve
promises.
You're going to see me recursively call this
function again and
again, every single time I get a new value
out of a promise.
So we go up
here, first time around, the last result is
undefined, haven't gotten
any yet, as soon as I call next, notice up
there at the top, execution stops
at the first yield and we return a promise
that symbolizes the eventual
stock symbol.
And that gets returned to the consumer.
If it's a
promise, the consumer calls then on it.
Notice here we're passing on the
onresult function we started with.
If but this time when the on result
function is called it's going to get the result
of that promise.
So as soon as
I do this, we're going to hop up back here,
and the last promise result is
going to be whatever came out of that promise.
JNJ.
So now I got the
result of the promise as a producer, but I
want to push it back -- excuse me,
the consumer.
I want to push it book back to the producer.
So I call next.
I
pass back in JNJ as the argument, you look
at the top there, notice what
happens to the yield symbol promise expression
-- it gets replaced with JNJ
and execution resumes and stops at the next
yield point.
So get symbol price
is a promise that eventually resolves to the
price.
That's what comes
out to the consumer.
Another promise.
We call then on it again.
Pass in on
result, that recursively gets resolved to
the next promise, which is the
price.
We call next, yield gets replaced with that
price, and then we continue
on to the very end of the generator function,
at which point it comes out
and says -- you know what?
Done is true.
We're not going to get any more
values.
Consumer takes that, doesn't need to resolve
it, it's not a
promise, and then resolves the overall promise
that was returned from
spawn to that final value.
And that's how asynchronous iteration works.
And that's how you can write
code at the top, right?
That looks like it blocks, but it actually
waits.
So
there is this spawn function actually defined
in a library that you can go and
try, which is called task.js.
If you're using a transpiler that allows you
to use yield in your code or you're using
a browser that is ES2015
capable, lucky you, you can do this today.
You can download the spawn
function, which is in task.js.
So that's how asynchronous functions work
and how generators interact with promises
to produce this pretty
impressive code.
But why should we have to download a library
to do
this?
This is going to be a common expression in
JavaScript.
Why do we need
a library?
Why can't we have direct support in the JavaScript
language for
this?
And that is our first feature today from ES2016,
and its async
functions.
And now you guys know everything you need
to know about how
async functions need to work.
They are like sugar over what you just saw.
This combination of spawn and yield -- soon
in the next version of JavaScript
you'll be able to write code like this, on
the left hand side.
For those
of you who are familiar with C#, this feature
is there as well.
You can just
put the word async in front of any function
and then inside of there, any
time you want to pause until a promise has
been resolved, you can throw a
wait in there.
So that's what's coming in the next version
of JavaScript.
So
we're getting closer to this vision of symmetrical
support for blocking and
waiting in JavaScript.
Right?
If I want to wait, I throw an async in front
of that function.
I
throw a few waits in there.
If I want to block, I take them out.
In order to
talk about any features in the next version
of JavaScript, responsibly, we
have talk about the ES feature maturity stages.
So as we develop new protocols
in JavaScript committee, we have to give time
to move them out.
So I'm going
to tell you about which stage it is in maturity.
So async functions are in
the draft stage.
That means that the committee expects the
feature to be
developed and included in the standard.
I think it's very, very likely
we're going to see async functions in the
next version of JavaScript.
It's
definitely something you can play with today
if you use Babel or a
transpiler, like Tracer.
Right now.
If you want to.
Go ahead, try it out.
That's why it's there.
And give us your feedback.
You can try it in Babel, if
you want to try it in Regenerator as well
-- I think they're in the main
branch.
Babel is probably the easiest and most likely
way by which you're
going to try this feature.
The await keyboard makes it easy to await
one
asynchronous value.
What if you want to wait on multiple values?
We await
multiple values all the time.
Web sockets, DOM events.
Lots of streams of
information that are being pushed at us, and
there's no real language
support for traversing those streams of information.
Now, in ES6, all collections became iterable.
And it's a contract.
If you
walk up to the array, for example, it means
you can ask that array for an
iterator, and gradually consume its items
one at a time by pulling them out.
Here's an example.
I can call this symbol.iterator method and
get out an
iterator and keep looping and calling next.
That's annoying, a lot of
boilerplate, which is why in ES2016 we introduced
this for of loop.
So
there's a couple of new collections coming
in ES6 as well, like maps, and you
can use this -- to consume that data.
Progressively.
So that's
what the new for of loop is for.
It just desugars to what you see on the left
hand side.
Now, if we can wait for values that we can
pull out, for streams
of values that we can pull out, why can't
we wait for streams of values that
are being pushed at us?
Why can't we have an equal support, like a
loop for
consuming data that comes out of a web socket,
or comes out of async IO, for
example?
That's the logic behind the proposed for on
loop for the next
version of JavaScript.
If you can have a for of, why can't you have
a for
on?
So I'm creating an async function and inside
I'm consuming the prices
from a web socket.
And the very first price differential that's
over a
certain threshold -- I'm going to resolve
the promise and grab that
particular diff between the previous price
and the next price.
No callbacks required.
I'm just looping over a stream of information
being
pushed at me.
So this would be great to do.
Right?
Now when I run this, it
resolves to a promise to give you the next
price spike in this stream of
stock prices.
But there's a little problem.
There's a reason we can't
have nice things just yet.
Right?
The problem is that the web has no
standard observable interface.
We have iterable.
As of ES6, this contract
you saw earlier, what you call symbol.iterator.
But today we have this
proliferation of different APIs that push
us streams of data.
That push
us data in a callback in a streamed way.
DOM events, web sockets, node
streams, XHTML requests -- can all push you
values.
But they don't
implement one common interface.
So one thing proposed for ES2016 is the
observable contract.
So here we have the iterable contract, introduced
in
2015.
How are we going to get the observable contract?
It's hidden
inside of this type.
If we just swap the arguments and the return
type of the
iterable what pops out is an observable.
An observable accepts a
generator, and then uses the push side of
the generator, and pushes
multiple values in it until it finally calls
return to signal that no
more values are coming.
If you think about it, iteration and observation
are both about the same thing.
Both about a producer giving a consumer
multiple values.
The difference is in one circumstance with
DOM
events, the data is being pushed to you.
But when you're using an iterator to pull
values out of an array, you're
pulling values.
Right?
In iteration, the consumer is in control,
and in
observation, the producer is in control.
The web socket decides when it
calls you.
So it's sort of like they're it rating you.
The producer is
iterating you by calling your callback.
So how does observation work?
The
consumer and producer and the relationship
with iteration -- it's the exact
same process but kind of the inverse.
So here the producer, instead of the
consumer requesting a generator from the producer,
the producer -- or the
consumer hands a generator to the producer.
And in this context, just think
about a generator as like three callbacks.
It's got the next, the throw,
and the return callbacks.
Just like you're handing an API three callbacks
and
expecting it to push information to you by
calling your callbacks.
So the
producer produces a value and calls the next
method on your generator,
the one you provided to it, and that's how
it pushes 42 to you, and
pushes another value and at its leisure, decides
to push 39 to you, until
finally it says you know what?
There's no more data coming.
So it calls
return to indicate to you no more data will
arrive.
So observation and iteration are actually
deeply linked.
As we saw, we can
turn one inside out and get the other.
So this is what it would look like to
consume a web socket or a DOM event that implemented
this contract.
You could just walk up to any of these data
sources and hand it a
generator, which is these three callbacks,
and then it will just push
streams of data at you.
Until it tells you it's done.
So we can add sugar,
just like we added sugar for iteration, for
that whole process of calling
symbol.iterator, and that while loop, and
checking the done property, just
like we can add sugar for that, we can add
sugar for observation.
A 4H
method, for example, to an observer that returned
a promise when it resolved,
or, as I showed you guys earlier, now that
we have a well defined method for
observation, which we do, a for on loop.
So the push stream can be done
entirely without callbacks.
So the hope would be if we introduce observable,
all the push APIs on the web can implement
this contract and all of a
sudden we can just add language support magically
for all of these different
push data sources.
So if I wanted to consume an observable in
ES2016, at least as the proposal
stands, I could do something like this.
And this is just going to keep
printing out new sign-ups at Netflix.
Just going to keep going.
So...
If an
async function returns a promise, and a function
star returns an iterator,
we as language designers have a question to
answer.
What does an async
function star return?
You can't just go adding features to languages
and
not describing what happens when you put them
together, when they
interact.
Well, there's a couple of different opinions
about this.
And
there's actually a couple different ways the
committee could go.
I'm
here today to tell you about one particular
option.
So if we look at
this table, we've got synchronous functions,
which return a value, synchronous
generators, which return multiple values,
you can pull multiple values out of
-- but we also have asynchronous functions,
which return a promise, and a
promise pushes you one value.
Right?
You give it a callback and it pushes the
value on that callback.
But what goes here?
Well, if a function star returns multiple
values, and an async function
pushes one value, maybe an async function
star pushes multiple values.
And
what type pushes us multiple values?
An observable.
So we can
envision, in the next version of JavaScript,
an async function star, which
pushes -- which actually returns you an observable.
So you could
build an asynchronous generator function,
which consumes data, stock data,
for example, and then translates it and produces
new stock data.
So now,
instead of just getting the next price spike
from a web socket, I want to get
all the price spikes from a web socket.
I'm going to use the for on loop and
yield inside of async function star, and this
whole thing is going to
produce an observable that pushes me all the
price spikes, all the stock
differences, when one stock comes along and
another stock comes along,
and that price difference is over a certain
threshold, just going to
push it on through to me.
And if I want to consume this, I can just
use for
on, inside of an async function.
And print to the console.
So what does that
mean?
It means symmetrical support for functions
that return multiple
values.
Whether they're push or they're pull.
You guys can stop worrying about the machinery
and the callbacks and just
focus on your code.
So...
This particular proposal -- I just want to
call out -- is at the strawman phase.
The earliest phase of the process.
So
we're definitely going to be thinking about
this more, and this may not make
it through as a final feature.
Just want to make that clear.
It's very early
in the feature stages.
We're looking for feedback on this.
So we want to hear
from you about whether this works for you
and solves your problems.
So
thanks very much, everybody.
Here are some resources for you, and
that's the end of my talk.